I have to make a shopping list the kids
are going to want snacks don't feed them
Kitty that's how it started the first
time it was kind of this amazing full
circle moment Ashton Kutcher Mila Kunis
Topher Grace Laura Prepon and Wilmer
Valderrama welcome back to chess says
it's always an honor to have your hair
in my chair
are just some of the OG cast members of
That 70s Show returning for the highly
anticipated Revival that 90s show I
think that anyone that's ever watched
70s that was a fan
I think would be very very very very
happy with how they the inciting
incident of this of the whole series
it's a continuation of the Beloved Fox
sitcom which followed a group of teenage
friends and their coming of age in 1970s
Wisconsin best I can't believe you
finally lost your virginity wait wait
this isn't like the time you bought a
hamster named it virginity and then lost
it
that 90s show picks up 20 years later
with a whole new cast of Rebel teens
back in the Foreman's basement
hey Grandma hey Grandpa Leia yep Kitty
in red AKA Deborah Joe rubb and Kirkwood
Smith return two this time their Grandma
and Grandpa's to Eric and Donna's teen
daughter Leia who's spending the summer
of 1995 in Wisconsin okay
[Music]
and Leia makes friends with a group of
Misfits just like her
and we'll just hooked us up what is it
Leia do you want to hear about the
Donkey Kong conspiracy
you'll know the secret sauce is going to
be there now when it comes to your
favorite That 70s Show Stars they won't
be completely lost in the sauce Wilmer
valderrama's beloved character Fez is
all grown up living a Glamorous Life as
a hair stylist at the end of the Netflix
trailer we get a glimpse of Ashton
Kutcher and Mila Kunis's character
Jackie and Kelso all grown up did it
like freak your head a little bit when
you said okay I'm going back to do this
and now I'm married to this man
let me tell you first and foremost my
child without giving too much away in
this show is way too old to be my child
so I was like what what are we like teen
pair like that's so okay I was like
whatever so first of all my kids way too
old I want everybody to know not
possible
um it is it's very good it's great in
fact it's been 16 years since That 70s
Show went off air but we have a feeling
that 90s show can recapture some of the
magic of the OG which ET had a front row
seat to during the show's eight year run
isn't it all
at all we're gonna spray paint our names
on a trailer all right I uh
naively and stupidly thought sure will
be a big hit and only now looking back
do I realize when we started the odds of
a show being successful when you start
as a pilot you know
but I think that kind of blind optimism
that we all had at the beginning
um
fueled us to get to this point easy was
there as a show said goodbye too and
Mila reflected on the journey okay we
have today I started this when I was 14.
I mean I went for like puberty on the
show there's certain things I will never
forget because it's documented
[Music]